a canção todos e na onu laura em estilo
[Música]
lá eu falasse telhado pensava também
negocia de estoque cozinha e o ouro com
funk na poesia o dólar ou uma palavra
significa apenas um nome e é
[Música]
simplesmente chamar depois com fome
é uma situação dessas formas não visa a
fio na forma da lei
o branco da áfrica mais ou embaixo dos
ferros e joão santos primário dessa
posição da rua para dizer como e
procurar outras formas que só consigo
porque é que todas as formas e
[Música]
é peter com um porque isso é obviamente
a intervenção foi o conteúdo é uma foto
do sul exatamente isso um dia na nossa
linguagem
fui de todas as formas e poeta dizia o
velho e bom
[Música]
e com ele é de conhecimento e deixaremos
de produzir mudanças sociais
o homem usava embaixo
[Música]
só que o photo na transição implicaria a
extinção das formas e e em tudo se nova
iguaçu
nesse tempo qualquer brasileiro
sabemos que deixou ao público em quase
qualquer fazer a nossa festa produzir e
encontrar coisas novas
encontrar um outro
[Música]
com ele dentro de casa nós sabemos o
quanto eu não sabia da decisão sobre o
juro é ganhar outro lado o que se viu
cinco anos nessa estréia
mas o que acontece enquanto toró é e
atendendo às suas relações estagnadas
a conversa de maior especialização ao
desenvolvimento tecnológico sentir a
galera produziu o movimento tecnológico
e científico da linguagem
[Música]
o tempo está a filha mais nova com as
formas e movimentos pró com isso
[Música]
e há muito que falar com a mãe ou
justificou a ação militar é melhor assim
porque é fácil compreensão
mas o meia só não seja cumprida a
exigência aqui uma coisa nova e ainda
ajudar só isso é a onu
[Música]
lá da sua língua da terra o seu i igreja
e 5 ó tentar encontrar a fórmula 1 moto
um f5f uma linguagem
[Música]